[Music]
there is a war out there and we need to
recognize that we've got to armor up
this far right racist
sexist supreme court that made this
decision based upon politics you see
this turn out here
you ain't seen nothing yet the hell with
the supreme court we will defy them
aoc and maxine waters calling for people
to get into the streets his left-wing
radicals vow violence in the wake of
today's supreme court ruling overturning
roe versus wade security being beefed up
around the supreme court in justice's
homes that while groups like jane's
revenge are planning a night of rage and
said it was open season on the pro-life
movement at least 40 pregnancy centers
have been vandalized and activists have
been allowed to illegally protest
outside justice's homes with one
deranged man trying to assassinate
justice brett kavanaugh and after weeks
of silence president joe biden finally
calling for peaceful protests
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protests peaceful
peaceful peaceful peaceful
no intimidation
violence is never acceptable
threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence in any
form
regardless of your rationale
so dana for six weeks we've seen the
white house encourage intimidation
outside of the justices homes and now
that homeland security is saying there
may be real violence he wants to step in
and try and get ahead of it well and you
know the attorney general could have
arrested any of those protesters at any
time because it is against the law the
federal law to protest outside of
justice's home they didn't do it and now
actually
the attorney general went to kiev and
i'm all for it like go help support the
ukrainians great but on your way out
could you issue a statement or some
guidance to the department of justice to
actually do their jobs and enforce the
law and they didn't do that so now there
was there was no deterrence
so now biden six weeks later is like oh
and please be peaceful that nobody's
listening to him anyway at this point
so
if there is violence
immediately they've got to put
put that out or else it will just
continue to simmer and the other thing
like when maxine waters says screw the
supreme court we'll defy them i mean the
way to do that would be to argue
persuasively in the states and to be
organized and i think that they do have
a fundamental problem though that it
seems the left has long had this
disconnect with getting a lot of money
from a small group of people on this
issue
and then the voters aren't necessarily
there for them because we are if you
look at any of the issues any of the
elections we've had recently the
primaries but your number one issue
inflation gas prices crime immigration
uh
even uh
uh education education missing a couple
of others and then it's like climate
change and then abortion right so this
is really this is obviously seismic who
knows but in november on election night
martha and i could be sitting there
saying wow abortion is the number one
issue i just kind of find that hard to
believe so hard to imagine you know
jaina makes the point that these
lawmakers on capitol hill could
say the states need to basically figure
this out congress also could pass laws
to do this however the last law they
tried to pass was so outrageous and
expanded roe to the point of partial
birth abortion that democrats in
washington who have a complete majority
on everything can't get it passed so
is there message here to get out in the
streets and do what since legislation
seems to be off the table for maxine
waters
you need to be very specific when you
tell anyone to go anywhere because there
are nut cases amongst all of us right
we have mental health problems um and
political and political extremism are a
terrible mix and the left and the right
both have them so i don't like any of
this talk i was very happy to see
president biden be so declarative and so
clear about this at that at this
particular moment but i've gotten this
question a lot today specifically about
doing this in 08 when obama had the
super majority why was there not a
codification of roe on a national level
and i think unfortunately that we take
too many things for granted and that
people have only so much political
capital he knew that the aca was going
to be his crowning achievement and so he
moved on this thing that's gotten
healthcare for over 20 million people
it's a really big deal and it was hugely
important but now we're looking back at
so many decisions like ruth bader
ginsburg deciding not to retire
nuking the filibuster and saying to
ourselves we have something that over 60
of americans agree about to some level
i'm not saying up until the point of
birth but certainly in the first
trimester and now we're staring down the
barrel of potentially half of the states
restricting this at the six week mark
and we have to be smarter about it it
will not be the number one issue but it
already has jumped 17 points since the
league came out and this will matter
yeah so martha you know the debate about
this issue is always very heated and the
left just seems like they don't want
debate on this i'm on the board of the
network of enlightened women and they
had their annual conference on capitol
hill today it's a group of pro-life
conservative women and the conference
had to be canceled because of the
threats that are happening on capitol
hill today so
you know it doesn't seem like they're
open to much debate in the wake of this
decision yeah well you know i would say
if you're in favor of choice then you
truly should be in favor of choice so if
someone wants to go to a pregnancy
center if they want to carry their baby
to term and adopt it you should be in
favor of protecting that right for them
as well so
it really makes you question you know
are you just pro-abortion or are you
truly pro-choice the other thing that i
would just mention is that you know i
look at president biden i look at nancy
pelosi who are both catholics who claim
to be both prep you know practicing
catholics and i didn't hear once from
either one of them today
you know look
my faith
is on the side of
ending abortion in this country but i
respect
that this is the decision that has been
made but from the courts and i respect
people's right to protest um why don't
they say that why don't they ever
mention their own faith i looked up it's
been quite a long time since president
biden has brought this part of the story
up and it just seems disingenuous to not
say that at this point and especially
say that in the context of you know we
believe in peaceful protest and make
sure that no one is hurt in in the
carrying out of your protest over this
weekend it would be nice to see some
respect for their faith in terms of the
way they're talking about this today
well greg here we are again you know
businesses in downtown dc are boarding
up as we speak and they're prepared and
the question is like why would they be
doing that what's the purpose of the
fence outside the supreme court today i
have no you know the thing is you know
for
viewers of this show i think we should
tell them that violence is never
acceptable even though there will be no
fan mail friday
but you're going to have to just deal
with that now if they choose if they
choose to bump my show which we taped
with dana at 11 p.m if they bump it
because something's going on in dc then
all bets are off you can burn the whole
place down okay burn it all down no i'm
kidding actually that's the funny thing
we never have to tell our fans or
republicans
don't riot yeah have we ever i mean it's
like
it's like dems rage
it's like it's like it's one word right
is there any other kind of rage we
learned that violence is actually an
effective tool in influencing justice
you witnessed the ferguson effect you
witnessed the rioters and the arsonists
the flow after the floyd during the
floyd riots were they were effectively
shielded from exposure because they were
the right kind of protest and they're
always the right kind of protest on that
side meanwhile you know if some guy
walks around on an unguided tour in
january 6 and he's in jail for life for
however long he's been in jail but we've
seen this on the left campuses shutting
down
speakers targeted trump supporters
attacked early on remember that when
trump got elected you remember that none
of that stuff seemed to matter violence
became their own language because they
felt above and beyond debate and that's
the problem these days in woke culture
is that debate is no longer necessary
you just you just get violent because
that those are words violence is words
words are violence i just add quickly
there's been a lot of violence at
planned parenthood clinics there was a
federal
and backwards and backwards but we only
have 30 minutes and i'm not doing 32
minutes
all right coming up how democrats in the
media distorted the reality of today's
historic supreme court abortion decision
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now